WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM YET, SO WE
WON'T DO ROLL CALL YET, BECAUSE
IT'LL ONLY PROVE WHAT I JUST
SAID, WHICH IS NO QUORUM, BUT WE
CAN START HEARING AS,
SUBCOMMITTEE. BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT, LET ME JUST INDICATE THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS ON
CONSENT. WE HAVE 13 BILLS TOTAL.
AND THE BILLS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT ARE ITEM ONE, AB 1782,
ITEM TWO, AB 1801, ITEM FIVE, AB
2570, ITEM SIX AB 2663. ITEM
SEVEN AB 2694. ITEM EIGHT H.J.R.
14 AND ITEM 12 AB 3122. SO THOSE
ARE THE BILLS ON CONSENT, BUT
SINCE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE,
WHO IS ALSO THE FIRST ON ORDER,
GIVEN THE PREVIOUS TWO BILLS ARE
ON CONSENT, THAT'S, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. SO YOU MAY BEGIN
WITH AB 2114. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 2114.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA AUTHORIZES
ARCHITECTS AND STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS TO PERFORM BALCONY
INSPECTIONS FOR COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS AS STATUTORY AS THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE FOR THESE
INSPECTIONS OF JANUARY 1ST,
2025, QUICKLY APPROACHES, IT HAS
BECOME BECOME CLEAR THAT THERE
IS A LACK OF AVAILABLE
INSPECTORS TO PERFORM THE WORK
TO MEET THIS DEADLINE. AB 2114
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
AUTHORIZING CIVIL ENGINEERS TO
PERFORM THESE INSPECTIONS. CIVIL
ENGINEERS ARE HIGHLY QUALIFIED
TO PERFORM THIS TASK AND
AUTHORIZING THEM WILL INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF ELIGIBLE
INSPECTORS. FOR THIS CRITICALLY
NECESSARY, TASK. WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS LOUIE BROWN,
REPRESENTING THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE. PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, LOUIE BROWN, HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE,
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE, WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL AND ARE ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OUR MEMBERS ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. WE WERE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON SB 326 BY
SENATOR HILL WHEN THE BILL WAS
PASSED. AND AS WE QUICKLY
APPROACH THE DEADLINE OF JANUARY
1ST 25, I BELIEVE THAT THE
INCLUSION OF CIVIL ENGINEERS
WILL NOT ONLY HELP MANY OF THOSE
ASSOCIATIONS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO FIND QUALIFIED
INSPECTORS, BUT WILL ALSO HELP
THOSE ASSOCIATIONS THAT ENGAGE
IN THIS EARLY ON AND WILL START
DOING THE RE INSPECTIONS HERE
SHORTLY AFTER JANUARY 1ST, 2025.
SO WITH THAT, WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME TO THE MIC. MADAM
CHAIR CARLOS GUTIERREZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, AUDREY
RITECHECK FROM CRUZ STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION.
NAIOP CALIFORNIA AND BOMA,
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. MEG
SNYDER, AXIOM ADVISORS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT ANY OTHERS. OKAY. DO
WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM? OKAY. SEEING NONE DO OUR
MEMBERS WANT TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS? AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
THE ROLL CALL AS SOON AS YOU
MADE SOME COMMENTS, IF YOU HAVE
ANY TO MAKE NO. OKAY. THEN LET'S
DO A ROLL CALL. WE DON'T YET
HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY. I WAS
LOOKING AT ALL THESE GOOD PEOPLE
AND THINKING WE DID. OH, WELL,
OKAY, THAT MEANS WE CAN'T TAKE
OUR MOTION YET, BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY HEAR YOUR CLOTHES,
CERTAINLY I DO. I SHOULD HAVE
MENTIONED ALSO THAT THIS, WE DO
HAVE A, URGENCY ON THIS. OKAY.
AND SO WE CAN HAVE THE CIVIL
ENGINEERS START WORKING AS SOON
AS WE GET THE GOVERNOR'S
SIGNATURE. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT. GREAT.
SO WE CAN'T EVEN REGISTER A
MOTION YET, RIGHT? NO. WE CAN'T.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. APPRECIATE
YOUR, BRINGING THE BILL BEFORE I
KNOW YOU'RE AWARE THAT, THERE'S
BEEN, BALCONY ACCIDENTS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE, BUT THE MOST
SERIOUS ONE IN RECENT MEMORY
OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT, AND IT
WAS, DEFINITELY A PROBLEM WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION. THAT PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
CAUGHT WITH APPROPRIATE
INSPECTIONS. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THE BILL. THANKS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, WE
WILL NOW GO TO AND I SEE THIS
AUTHOR HERE, ITEM FOR AB 2338
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
OKAY. SO SOME OF THAT. YEAH I
DON'T THINK THEY CARE ABOUT IT
THAT MUCH, BUT MAYBE THEY DO
THINK SO. I DON'T THINK WE DON'T
EVEN GET A LETTER FROM THEM.
YES. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I PRESENT AB 2338,
WHICH STRENGTHENS CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO THE HOMELESSNESS TO
HOMELESSNESS BY BY ESTABLISHING
A STATEWIDE HOMELESS COORDINATOR
AS THE LEAD ENTITY FOR ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INVESTED TO ASSIST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SUPPORT HOUSING
PROGRAMS, WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE NATION'S LARGEST HOMELESS
POPULATION. THIS IS, IN FACT,
DUE TO THE NATION'S DISJOINTED
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. AB 2338 WILL
ENSURE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
COORDINATION TO END HOMELESSNESS
BY REQUIRING THE GOVERNOR TO
APPOINT A STATEWIDE HOMELESS
COORDINATOR. THE COORDINATOR
WILL SET GOALS TO END
HOMELESSNESS, OVERSEE RELATED
PROGRAMS, SERVICES, DATA AND
POLICIES BETWEEN FEDERAL, STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES, AS WELL AS
COORDINATING THE TIMING OF THE
RELEASE OF STATE FUNDS AND
FUNDING APPLICATIONS FOR HOUSING
AND HOUSING BASED SERVICES. THIS
BILL PROVIDES THE COORDINATOR
FLEXIBILITY TO IDENTIFY A LOCAL
LEADER, LEADER, AND THE
APPROPRIATE JURISDICTION TO
SERVE AS A LIAISON TO THE STATE
AND IN COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
LEADERS, THE COORDINATOR WILL
PROVIDE ANNUAL RECOMMENDATIONS
TO LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
WHILE THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
OVERLAP IN A LOT OF EXISTING
RESOURCES, MANY TIMES WE SEE
INDIVIDUALS GOING TO DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND LOSING VALUABLE
TIME WHEN THEY COULD HAVE
RECEIVED HELP. AB 2338 IS
PUTTING IS ABOUT PUTTING A
PERSON IN CHARGE THAT PEOPLE CAN
LOOK TO FOR GUIDANCE, NOT
CREATING A NEW BUREAUCRACY.
LASTLY, I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE I
WILL BE AMENDING THIS BILL IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT IN THE FORM
OF SENATE RULES. APPROVAL OF THE
NOMINEE, AS SUGGESTED BY THE
SENATOR FROM YUCAIPA LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE IF
THERE'S A KEY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
, I'M THE KEY WITNESS. YOU'RE
THE KEY WITNESS. YOU'RE IT. AND
THERE'S NOT OPPOSITION EITHER.
ANY ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM FOR
EITHER OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT FOR
AB TWO THREE, THREE EIGHT. OKAY.
SO SEEING THAT WE WILL WE CAN
HAVE DISCUSSION EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE A SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DOES ANYONE HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? NO. AND YOU MORE OR
LESS CLOSED. BUT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SAY FURTHER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN WE HAVE OUR QUORUM AND
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY.
APPRECIATE THAT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES. SAWYER ALL RIGHT, I SEE
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNELLY IS
HERE, SO WE'LL GO TO HIS ITEM.
THAT'S, ITEM NINE AB 2897.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNELLY. YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. GOOD AFTERNOON. AB
2897 WILL UPDATE THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE USED TO DEFINE A
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST, OR CLT, AS
THEY'RE KNOWN IN STATE LAW, TO
REFLECT, REFLECT THE FULL RANGE
OF PURPOSES. A COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST SERVES. TODAY, AB 2897
ALSO ADDRESSES A TECHNICAL
CROSS-REFERENCING CORRECTION IN
EXISTING LAW THAT ALLOWS
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS TO
MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY TAX
WELFARE EXEMPTION UNDER THE SAME
CIRCUMSTANCES AS LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROJECTS.
CLTS ARE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT STEWARD
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY AS
AFFORDABLE PERMANENT HOUSING.
ALTHOUGH THE CLT MODEL IS WELL
KNOWN FOR PROVIDING HOUSING, IT
IS INTENDED TO BE FLEXIBLE,
ALLOWING FOR COMMUNITY
CONTROLLED BUSINESSES, SERVICES,
OR OTHER KINDS OF ORGANIZATIONAL
ADAPTATION DEPENDING ON
COMMUNITY NEED. HOWEVER THE
EXISTING STATUTORY DEFINITION IS
OVERLY NARROW AND EXCLUDES SOME
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS WITH
DIVERSE AND NONRESIDENTIAL
PRACTICES FROM FALLING WITHIN
THE CATEGORY. FOR EXAMPLE, CLTS
FACILITATES STEWARDSHIP OF A
COMMUNITY RESOURCE SUCH AS A
GARDEN, NONPROFIT OFFICE SPACE,
OR SMALL BUSINESS. RETAIL MAY
NOT FALL UNDER THE CURRENT
STATUTORY DEFINITION. CLT
PROPERTIES RENTED TO TENANTS ARE
OFTEN ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROPERTY
TAX WELFARE EXEMPTION, AND IN
2022, AB 1206 AUTHORIZED
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS TO KEEP
THEIR WELFARE WELFARE EXEMPTION
EVEN IF ONE OR MORE RESIDENTS
INCOME INCREASES. THIS GIVES
CLTS FLEXIBILITY IN DETERMINING
WHO QUALIFIES AS LOW INCOME, SO
RESIDENTS CAN MAINTAIN THEIR
HOUSING SECURITY EVEN IF THEY
GET A PROMOTION OR RAISE. THIS
BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I WILL NOW
PASS IT TO MY WITNESS, AMY
HINES. CHIC, REPRESENTING THE
BILL'S SPONSOR, THE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST NETWORK. THANK YOU,
HONORABLE CHAIR SKINNER AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS AMY
HINES-IKE, AND I'M REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK, WHICH HAS
APPROXIMATELY 40 AFFILIATES IN
ALL AREAS OF OUR STATE FROM THE
OREGON BORDER DOWN TO SAN DIEGO,
WITH APPROXIMATELY 3500
RESIDENTS LIVING IN COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST PROPERTIES. THE FIRST
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST GREW OUT OF
THE SOUTHERN CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AS A TOOL FOR
ESTABLISHING A NEW FORM OF LAND
TENURE FOR BLACK FARMERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT WHILE THE
ORIGINAL CLTS INCLUDED FARMING
AND HOUSING, OUR CURRENT LEGAL
DEFINITION IN CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT INCLUDE ALL THE WAYS THAT
OUR AFFILIATES STEWARD LAND FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. AB 2897
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNERLY,
WOULD FIX THAT. AB 2897 IS NOT
TRYING TO BROADEN WHO'S
CONSIDERED A CLT OR BROADEN WHO
RECEIVES A TAX EXEMPTION.
THEY'VE BEEN IN EXISTENCE SINCE
1970 AND ARE STILL DOING WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING SINCE THEN.
ALL WE'RE DOING IS TRYING TO
MAKE THE CLT DEFINITION LEGAL,
DEFINITION ON PAPER, MATCH
WHAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND. CLTS OPERATE COMMUNITY
GARDENS, NONPROFIT SPACES AND
OTHER COMMUNITY OWNERSHIP
PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITY. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
CONNERLY JUST OUTLINED, IT IS
COMMON FOR CLT PRESERVATION
PROJECTS TO INVOLVE THE
ACQUISITION OF AN APARTMENT
BUILDING AND THEN A MULTI YEAR
TRANSITION TO CLT HOME
OWNERSHIP. DURING THAT
TRANSITION, THESE BUILDINGS ARE
TYPICAL SIMPLE RENTALS WITH NO
GROUND LEASE. WE ARE UPDATING
THE DEFINITION OF A CLT TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS COMMON PRACTICE
. AB 2897 IS FIXING THE
DEFINITION OF A CLT TO MERELY
DESCRIBE THE WORK THAT CLTS ARE
ALREADY DOING, NOT BROADENING
THE BROADENING THE UNIVERSE OF
CLTS, AND NOT EXPANDING ANY
BENEFITS TO ORGANIZATIONS THAT
DON'T ALREADY HAVE A TAX
BENEFIT. WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 2897, AND WE
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNERLY
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU. GREAT. LET US
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER,
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE FOR AB
2897. OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED, BUT
IN CASE THERE ARE. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE IF THE, MEMBERS HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT ON THIS
BILL. AB 2897. YOU'RE LOOKING
GOOD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONLEY UP.
GO AHEAD. SENATOR, I LIKE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. AND I'LL MOVE
IT WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET OKAY,
OKAY, ALL RIGHT, SO SOME MEMBER
CONLEY, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
WONDERFUL OKAY, EXCELLENT. AND,
WE, WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS IN
COMMITTEE AND SUCH, AS SOON AS
WE HAVE THOSE FOLKS, WE WILL GET
QUORUM AND WE WILL START TAKING
THEM, MOTIONS. ALL RIGHT. WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM. WE NEED TO HAVE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA. SO KHÓ, PERHAPS THEY
GET THEIR OFFICES CALLED RIGHT.
WE HAVE MR. TANG. YAY! YOU ARE
READY FOR YOU. AND THAT'S AB
2967. THAT'S FINE. GREAT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AB 2967
EXPANDS THE TEACHER HOUSING ACT
TO EMPLOYEES OF PUBLICLY FUNDED
NONPROFITS THAT OPERATE ON
SCHOOL DISTRICT PROPERTY AND
SERVE CHILDREN FROM LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES. SO,
FOR EXAMPLE, AFTER SCHOOL
PROVIDERS, AS WELL AS
POTENTIALLY CHILD CARE CENTERS
THAT ARE PHYSICALLY ON SITE ON
SCHOOL DISTRICT PROPERTY, THIS
COMES FROM ONE OF MY COUNTY, SAN
MATEO COUNTY, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TAKEN REALLY THE FORESIGHT OF
BUILDING, HOUSING EMPLOYEE
HOUSING ON SOME OF THEIR SCHOOL
OWNED PROPERTY SITES. AND THEY
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO GIVE
OPPORTUNITY TO, EMPLOYEES OF
THESE NONPROFITS WHO WORK IN THE
DISTRICT BUT ARE NOT DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES. SO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE, VOTE ON AB 2967. ALL
RIGHT, LET US SEE, I DO THINK WE
HAVE SOME WITNESSES AND SUPPORT,
SO YOU MAY GO AHEAD, IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR SKINNER.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, AUDREY
RITECHECK FROM CRUZ STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO COUNTY,
SAN MATEO COUNTY IS A HIGH COST
BAY AREA COMMUNITY WITH PLANS TO
BUILD 20,000 NEW HOUSING UNITS
FOR OUR LOWER INCOME RESIDENTS
OVER THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS. ONE
OF OUR CRITICAL PROJECTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IS THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF A PROPERTY
CALLED MIDWAY VILLAGE. THIS SITE
WAS ONCE OWNED BY THE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT PRIOR TO IT
BEING CONVERTED TO PUBLIC
HOUSING. WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF REDEVELOPING THE
PROPERTY TO REPLACE ITS 150
AGING UNITS WITH 5555 NEW
AFFORDABLE HOMES, BUT ONE OF THE
CRITICAL THINGS WE'VE HEARD FROM
OUR EXTENSIVE COMMUNITY PLANNING
PROCESS WAS THE DESIRE TO
PROVIDE A PREFERENCE FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS LIKE EARLY
CHILDHOOD PRE-K AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS. EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS IN
CALIFORNIA EARN ALMOST 40% LESS
THAN THEIR COLLEAGUES IN THE K
THROUGH EIGHT SYSTEM, AND THEY
WOULD BE CONSIDERED EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME IN OUR COUNTY, WHERE
THE AVERAGE MONTHLY RENT IS OVER
$3,000. AND THESE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS FACE HOUSING
INSECURITY AND ARE OFTEN FORCED
TO LEAVE THE PROFESSION AND FIND
SECOND JOBS OR UNDERTAKE VERY
LONG COMMUTES. THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL BILLS PASSED IN RECENT
YEARS SUPPORTING THE BUILDING OF
MORE TEACHER HOUSING, BUT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
CREATED UNDER THE TEACHER
HOUSING ACT. SO WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT AB 2967 THAT WOULD
EXPAND THIS LAW BY EXTENDING
THESE CRITICAL, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES TO THIS
IMPORTANT GROUP OF EDUCATORS
THAT SET YOUNG CHILDREN FROM LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ON A PATH TO BETTER ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WANTS TO COME AND ADD ON. GOOD
AFTERNOON, DANIELLE BRADLEY, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. GREAT. ANY OTHERS?
OKAY. WE HAVE NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION, BUT LET'S JUST SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WHO WANTS TO INDICATE OPPOSITION
ON THE BILL. RIGHT. SEEING NONE
MEMBERS. GO AHEAD. SENATOR
BLAKE. THANK YOU. I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT BILL, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU DIDN'T MAKE
IT A DISTRICT BILL, BECAUSE NOW
IT CAN APPLY TO ALL OF THE
COUNTIES, 58 COUNTIES AND THE
ENTIRE STATE. SO THANK YOU. AND
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, I WILL
MOVE IT. GREAT ALL RIGHT. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR SEEING NONE
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER TIM, YOU
MAY CLOSE, YOU KNOW, JUST
RESPECTFULLY I VOTE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. I THINK IT'S
EXCITING. WHAT MANY DISTRICTS
ARE STARTING TO DO IS TAKE A
LOOK AT THEIR SURPLUS LAND AND
BUILD HOUSING. SO I THINK THIS
IS AN EXCITING OPPORTUNITY WITH
THAT RESPECT. TRANSFER FRONT.
GREAT. OKAY. WHEN WE HAVE OUR
QUORUM, WE TAKE MOTIONS. WE
WILL, SEE IF THAT WORKS. THANK
YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING. AND NOW WE ARE
LOOKING FOR TWO OTHER AUTHORS.
YOU SEE THEM OUT THERE? PHIL,
TELL THEM TO COME IN. YEAH YES,
PELLERIN AND MCKENNA.
WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, YOU CAN COME RIGHT TO
THE PODIUM.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE, WILL NOW BE
HEARING AB 3035 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
SKINNER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AB 30. LET ME GET MY
GLASSES. 3035, EXPAND AN
EXISTING STREAMLINED APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYEE HOUSING IN THE TWO
COUNTIES IN MY DISTRICT, SANTA
CLARA AND SANTA CRUZ. IN 2019,
SPEAKER RIVAS AUTHORED ASSEMBLY
BILL 1783, WHICH CREATED A
STREAMLINED MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR QUALIFYING
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE HOUSING
PROJECTS. THE PROJECTS PROPOSED
PURSUANT TO THAT BILL ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET NUMEROUS
CRITERIA, INCLUDING THAT THEY
MUST BE LOCATED ON LANDS
DESIGNATED FOR AGRICULTURE IN
THE GENERAL PLAN, AND THAT
PROJECTS MUST INCLUDE NO MORE
THAN 36 UNITS. UNFORTUNATELY
THESE LIMITATIONS MEAN THAT
THERE ARE FEW PROJECTS THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY QUALIFY FOR
STREAMLINING IN MY DISTRICT, IN
PARTICULAR, THOSE MOST SITES IN
MY DISTRICT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY QUALIFY FOR AB 1783
ARE OUTSIDE OF CITIES AND OTHER
URBANIZED AREAS AND LACK THE
NEEDED WATER AND SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE. AB 3035 MAKES
TWO CHANGES TO BROADEN THE SITES
WHERE AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE
HOUSING CAN BE STREAMLINED IN
SANTA CLARA AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTIES. FIRST, IT EXPANDS THE
SITE QUALIFICATION TO INCLUDE
AREAS NEAR AGRICULTURAL LAND
THAT ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
WATER AND SEWER SERVICE THAT CAN
SUPPORT MULTI HOUSING, MULTI
UNIT HOUSING. SECOND, IT
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF UNITS
THAT CAN BE INCLUDED IN
QUALIFYING DEVELOPMENT TO
REFLECT THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
TYPICALLY REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
HOUSING IN EXPENSIVE HOUSING
MARKETS LIKE THOSE IN MY
DISTRICT. WHILE AB 3035 IS A
DISTRICT BILL, WE HOPE THAT THIS
PILOT PROJECT CAN HELP INFORM
FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES TO
STREAMLINE THIS MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING FOR FARMWORKERS
STATEWIDE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS DAVID CAMPOS, THE
DEPUTY COUNTY EXECUTIVE FOR THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA. GREAT.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. HONORABLE SENATORS.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, FOR CARRYING THIS BILL
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA. THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
AGRICULTURE, AND WE SEE ONE OF
OUR REPRESENTATIVES, SENATOR
CORTEZ, HERE. AND WE ARE PROUD
OF THAT HISTORY. BUT WITH THAT
HISTORY COMES THE FACT THAT WE
HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH TO HOUSE
THOSE FARM WORKERS THAT ACTUALLY
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE. AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT ALLOWS US
TO MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WHEN IT COMES TO MEETING THAT
CRITICAL NEED, AS OF TODAY, WE
HAVE A NEED OF 1400 HOUSING
UNITS FOR SEASONAL WORKERS, AS
WELL AS 700 LONG-TERM HOUSING
UNITS FOR THOSE WORKERS. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN INDICATED, IS
THAT IT MAKES TWO CRITICAL
CHANGES TO ALLOW THE COUNTY TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. ONE, IT EXPANDS THE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA OF WHAT? OF
WHERE THE, RIVAS BILL APPLIES,
BECAUSE THE CHALLENGE WITH THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE IS THAT THE
BILL EXPEDITES HOUSING IN
RURALLY ZONED AREAS, WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY LACK THE WATER AND
SEWER SYSTEM TO ACTUALLY MAKE
HOUSING, FEASIBLE, AFFORDABLE.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES, IT
ALLOWS US TO EXPAND TO INCLUDE
IN THE ZONING THOSE GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS THAT ARE BORDERING
AGRICULTURAL ZONES. THE SECOND
THING THAT IT DOES IS THAT IT
DOES INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT ARE ALLOWED TO BE
BUILT UNDER THIS STREAMLINED
PROCESS. PLEASE KNOW THAT THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA IS NOT
JUST ASKING THE STATE TO DO ITS
PART, BUT WE HAVE ACTUALLY TAKEN
VERY IMPORTANT STEPS BY ADOPTING
A VERY BROAD, AGRICULTURAL
WORKER HOUSING PLAN THAT
INCLUDES WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
STREAMLINE OUR OWN LOCAL PROCESS
AND ALSO ALLOCATES FUNDING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE HOUSING THAT
WE'RE ENVISIONING IS BUILT. WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT APPLIES TO TWO
COUNTIES, BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS CAN BE AN EXAMPLE OF HOW TO
MAKE THIS HOUSING HAPPEN. FOR A
POPULATION THAT HAS BEEN WAITING
FOR THE STATE TO MOVE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR QUITE SOME
TIME. SO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA, WE THANK AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN AND HER
AMAZING STAFF, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU. GREAT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO WANTS TO
ADD ON AS A SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ANYONE ELSE ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE. WE DON'T HAVE A REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. BUT IF THERE'S
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
3035, YOU CAN COME FORWARD NOW.
SEEING NONE. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS BY. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR BLAKESBURG I LIKE
IT. THIS IS A BILL THAT I
THOUGHT, WHY IS THIS A DISTRICT
BILL? THIS SHOULD BE A WHOLE
STATEWIDE BILL. DO YOU DO YOU
WANT TO SPEAK TO THAT? WELL, I,
WE WERE STARTING SMALL, BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO GO LARGER LATER.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE BUILD THIS MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING. AND I KNOW THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM OTHER COUNTIES THAT
MIGHT WANT TO BE IN THE BILL,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADD THEM IN IF
THEY'RE WILLING, IF THEY'RE
WANTING TO BE ADDED. OKAY,
GREAT. I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE. OKAY I THINK WE
HAVE SOME. THEY'RE TALKING.
YEAH. SO, SENATOR CORTEZ, JUST
JUST A COMMENT, YOU KNOW, THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU TO
COUNTY SANTA CLARA FOR,
SPONSORING THE LEGISLATION,
HAVING SERVED THERE ON THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS, YOU KNOW, IN
ADDITION TO JUST REPRESENTING
THE AREA, IN A NUMBER OF
POSITIONS OVER ALL THESE YEARS.
THIS IS, IS DEFINITELY VITALLY
NEEDED. AND IT'S ONE OF THOSE
AREAS. AND WE SEEM TO YOU KNOW,
HEAR THIS SO OFTEN IN HERE IN
THE CAPITOL. NOW THAT THAT
REALLY GOT SLOWED DOWN BY THE
PANDEMIC, THE COUNTY IT REALLY
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS
TAKEN SOME REAL SIGNIFICANT
STEPS ON ITS OWN FORWARD TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM, YOU
KNOW, IN THE 2017 TO 2019 TIME
FRAME AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
SUDDENLY YOU'VE GOT, YOU KNOW,
BUILDING DEPARTMENTS AND
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS AND, AND
FOLKS AND AGENCIES THAT ARE
EITHER, YOU KNOW, SHUT DOWN OR
TURNING ALL THEIR ATTENTION TO,
TO THE PANDEMIC WE WERE DEALING
WITH. AND IT'S JUST GREAT TO SEE
THE COUNTY AND REPRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S PELLERIN IN
THIS CASE, COMING RIGHT BACK. I
KNOW THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MADE THIS A HUGE PRIORITY ONCE
AGAIN. TO TRY TO GET CAUGHT UP
IN AND REALLY MEET THE NEEDS.
AND IT'S SUCH A REASONABLE, A
REASONABLE THING. AND, I TRUST
THE COUNTY VERY MUCH IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTING, WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN TERMS OF INTERFACING
WITH PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS AND
MAKING SURE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
THERE. SO AGAIN, JUST A COMMENT.
OF COURSE, I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL. THANK YOU, ALL RIGHT.
WELL, YOU MAY CLOSE. WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET, SO WE, CAN'T
TAKE OUR MOTION, BUT CERTAINLY
WELCOME TO WELL, I'M DEFINITELY
HONORED TO CARRY THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA AND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTIES. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT ALL RIGHT, WE WILL
NOW GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKINNON.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MEMBERS AND
CHAIR, THE MAYOR. I'M HERE TO,
TO TALK ABOUT AGRX NINE, THE
AMERICAN DREAM OF HOME OWNERSHIP
IS SLIPPING AWAY FROM THE
AVERAGE CITIZEN. AND THE
INABILITY TO OBTAIN AND KEEP
HOUSING HAS LED TO AN INCREASE
IN EVICTIONS AND CONTRIBUTING TO
THE INCREASE IN OUR UNHOUSED
POPULATION. A NATIONWIDE
SHORTAGE OF HOUSING UNITS IS
FURTHER MOVING. THAT DREAM AWAY
FOR MILLIONS OF AMERICANS. H.R.
NINE WOULD URGE THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS TO PASS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO SIGN THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE, WHICH
INCLUDES THREE GROUNDBREAKING
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
AFFORDABILITY, ACCESSIBILITY
HEAD ON. H.R. 4233. MAXINE
WATERS, THE HOUSING CRISIS
RESPONSE ACT OF 2023 WOULD
PROVIDE MORE THAN $150 BILLION
IN FAIR, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INVESTMENTS, WHICH WOULD BE THE
LARGEST INVESTMENTS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY. IT WOULD ALSO
CREATE A $1.4 MILLION AFFORDABLE
HOMES, AND WOULD ADDRESS THE
RACIAL WEALTH GAP THROUGH THE
FIRST EVER INVESTMENT IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP, HOMEOWNERSHIP.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, FIRST
GENERATION HOME BUYERS H.R. 4232
MAXINE WATERS THE ENDING
HOMELESSNESS ACT OF 2023 WOULD
REDUCE POVERTY IN AMERICA BY
TRANSFORMING THE HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHER PROGRAM INTO A FEDERAL
ENTITLEMENT, ALLOWING EVERY
HOUSEHOLD THAT QUALIFIES FOR
ASSISTANCE TO REVIEW IT TO
RECEIVE IT. IT WOULD ALSO BAN
HOUSING DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
INCOME AND VETERAN STATUS. H.R.
4231 MAXINE WATERS, THE DOWN
PAYMENT TOWARDS EQUITY ACT OF
2023 WOULD CLOSE THE U.S. RACIAL
WEALTH AND HOMEOWNERSHIP GAPS BY
BY PROVIDING $100 BILLION IN
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO HELP FIRST
TIME, FIRST GENERATION
HOMEBUYERS PURCHASE THEIR VERY
FIRST HOME. WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A HOUSING CRISIS AND KEEPING
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES AND OFF
THE STREETS SHOULD BE OUR TOP
PRIORITY. URGING CONGRESS AND
THE PRESIDENT TO ACT AND SIGN
THE HOUSING PACKAGE IS A CRUCIAL
STEP IN FULLY INVESTING IN AND
TACKLING OUR HOUSING CRISIS HEAD
ON, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE. THANK YOU. LET'S.
ONE IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY AT THE MIC? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION,
SO I'M ASSUMING THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. WANTS TO TESTIFY AT
THE MIC EITHER. BUT I ALWAYS
HAVE TO ASK, SO LET'S SEE. NOT
SO. COMMENTERS. YES, SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR, THANK YOU, SO I, I
WANT TO COMMENT ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE WHEN I WENT TO
WASHINGTON, DC TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE RAIL CORRIDOR AND
INVESTMENTS ON THE COASTAL RAIL
CORRIDOR, I SPENT SOME TIME ALSO
TALKING ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE IT'S A TOP ISSUE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND MEETING
WITH SOME OF THE OFFICIALS WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE BEALL FOR OUR
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT WHAT ARE THE AGENCIES
DOING IN WASHINGTON, DC TO
FORWARD THE BALL SO THAT WE CAN
BE DOING MORE INSTEAD OF DOING
THE SAME OR DOING LESS? AND THIS
BILL BY MAXINE WATERS, BY
REPRESENTATIVE WATERS IS A
REALLY GREAT EXAMPLE OF THAT,
BECAUSE SHE HAS PUT TOGETHER A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ACTIONS THAT
COULD ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND SO WHEN THERE IS
A RENEWED FOCUS ON HOMELESSNESS
IN CONGRESS, WHICH I HOPE IS
SOON IMMINENT, BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF I SEE THAT IN THE TEA LEAVES,
BUT I, I, I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE ELEVATING THIS AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO REALLY SUPPORT GOOD POLICY
AND ASK FOR FURTHER INVESTMENTS
SO THAT WE CAN BE ABLE TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS INSTEAD OF SEEING IT
INCREASE EVERY MONTH AS WE
CURRENTLY ARE. SO I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
UP. THANK YOU. AND I WILL MOVE
IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
GREAT. LET'S SEE IF ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. WE DON'T, BUT WE WILL
HAVE A QUORUM SOON. AND WHEN WE
DO HAVE THAT QUORUM, WE'LL, TAKE
MOTIONS. BUT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE, GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. WE
KNOW THAT HOUSING IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IN THIS STATE THAT
WE'RE TACKLING HOMELESSNESS AT
EVERY LEVEL, WE ALSO KNOW THAT
HOME OWNERSHIP IS VERY HARD TO
OBTAIN BY OUR BY OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE, BY OUR YOUTH, ESPECIALLY
OUR YOUNG ADULTS. AND SO TO HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, TO HAVE
THIS MONEY COME INTO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WOULD JUST BE
REMARKABLE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. GREAT.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER. AND
LIKE I SAID, AS SOON AS WE GET
OUR QUORUM, WE WILL START TAKING
MOTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO RECESS
UNTIL WE GET UNDERWAY? WHAT?
THIS IS.
ALL RIGHT. WE, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A ROLL CALL NOW. SEE IF WE
HAVE OUR QUORUM THAT WE'VE BEEN
HOPING TO HAVE. SENATOR SKINNER,
I'M HERE. SKINNER. HERE. OCHOA.
BOGUE. CHITTO. BOGUE HERE. BLAKE
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. HERE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ HERE. CORTEZ.
HERE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. HERE.
PADILLA CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE.
BURKE. WAHAB ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE
A QUORUM SO WE CAN STATE, WHAT
AM I SAYING? WE CAN START TAKING
MOTIONS, BUT LET'S FIRST GO BACK
TO THAT AGENDA WHERE, AS I
OPENED, I INDICATED THE BILLS
THAT WERE ON CONSENT. LET ME
REPEAT AGAIN. WHAT BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT? THEY ARE. ITEM ONE AB
1782, ITEM TWO AB 1801. ITEM
FIVE AB 2570 AB TWO EXCUSE ME
EIGHT. ITEM SIX AB 2663. ITEM
SEVEN AB 2694. ITEM EIGHT H.R.
14 AND ITEM 12 AB 3122. SO CAN I
HAVE A. SO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTEZ FOR CONSENT.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
OCHOA. AYE OCHOA. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. PADILLA.
CIERTO. CIERTO AYE. UMBER. WAHAB
620. OKAY THAT BILL WILL STAY ON
CALL. LET'S TAKE A MOTION ON AB
2114. ERWIN IS THERE A MOTION.
GO AHEAD. SENATOR BLAKE SPEERS
MOVED, LET'S CALL THE ROLL CALL
ON THAT ONE, MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE SKINNER.
AYE. OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI I BLAKE
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. I CABRERO.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. PADILLA SERRATO.
SERRATO. AYE. UMBER. WAHAB SIX
ZERO. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS 6
TO 0 NOW. BUT WE'LL KEEP IT ON
CALL. WE'LL GO TO AB 2338
JONES-SAWYER. THAT WOULD BE TWO
PASSED TO HUMAN SERVICES.
SENATOR BLAKE, YOU STILL WANT TO
BE THE MOTION MAKER? OKAY, BLAKE
SPEAR MOVED. ROLL CALL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
OCHOA. BORG NOT VOTING. BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
CABELLO CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR PADILLA. CIERTO UMBERG.
WAHAB WITH 3 TO 0. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL. IT'S 3 TO
0. LET'S GO TO ITEM NINE AB
2897. THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
COME ON. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
AB 2897. ALL RIGHT. SO CORTEZ
MOVED. WILL ROLL CALL. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE. SENATOR
SKINNER I SKINNER I OKOBOJI I
OKOBOJI I BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE
SPEAR I CABALLERO CORTEZ CORTEZ
I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I PADILLA
CIERTO CIERTO I UMBERG WAHAB SIX
ZERO. ALL RIGHT THAT BILL IS NOW
6 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
WE'LL GO TO AB 2967. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING. AND THAT IS, TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR FOR MOVED, WE
HAVE CORTEZ AS THE MOTION MAKER.
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL. SENATOR
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE, OKOBOJI.
I CHOBOQ I BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE
SPEAR, I CABALLERO. CORTEZ
CORTEZ. I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
PADILLA SERRATO. YOUNGBERG.
WAHAB. 5 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS NOW 5 TO 0. WE'LL KEEP
IT ON CALL. WE'LL GO TO ITEM 11
AB 3035 PELLERIN. AND WE WILL,
TAKE A MOTION FROM SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR, WHICH IS DUE PASS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. ROLL CALL,
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER I OCHOA
I BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I
CABRERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I PADILLA
CIERTO CIERTO I UMBERG AHAB 6 TO
0. ALL RIGHT. 6 TO 0. THAT'S,
THAT AB 3035 6 TO 0 WILL KEEP IT
ON CALL. WE'LL GO TO THE LAST
ITEM, WHICH IS ITEM 13 AJR9.
MACKINNON. DO WE HAVE A ROLL,
EXCUSE ME, A MOTION MOVED,
CORTEZ MOVED. ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO
APPROPRIATION. SENATOR SKINNER,
A SKINNER, A OCHOA BOG. NO, A
BOG NO. BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR
I CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR AND GUEVARA I PADILLA.
CIERTO. CIERTO NO. UMBERG. WAHAB
4 TO 2. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILLS 4
TO 2. WE'LL KEEP IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. GIVES ITS
CONSENT. THIS IS, PARALLEL
MEETINGS. SHE HAD AN EVENT AND
WE THANK THESE OTHER MEMBERS ARE
ON THE WAY BEFORE I START
REOPENING EVERYTHING AGAIN, I
CAN DOUBLE CHECK. YEAH, OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, SO, SENATOR WILL
HAVE IF YOU DON'T MIND, YOUR
OTHER TWO COLLEAGUES ARE ON
THEIR WAY, SO WE'LL OPEN THE
ROLL FOR ALL OF THEM, AND THEY
DON'T GET HERE WITHIN, A MINUTE
AND A HALF. WE'LL START OPENING
RULES.
FOR KIDS SIX YEARS OLD, THAT'S
PERFECT. IT'S INCREDIBLE. THANK
YOU.
HEY, MR. ROMBERG. YAY YOU'RE
HERE. WE WILL DO THE, REOPEN.
AND THE CALL WILL FIRST START
WITH THE, CONSENT. IT, AND,
HOPEFULLY I COULD REPEAT ALL THE
BILLS THAT ARE IN CONSENT, BUT
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE YOUR LIST IN
FRONT OF YOU, AND IT'S THE ONES
THAT ARE ASTERISKED. NOBODY
PULLED ANY CONSENT ITEMS. SO THE
, LET'S, PROCEED WITH ROLL CALL
ON IT. CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0.
SENATOR CABALLERO GUERRERO I
PADILLA UMBERG I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WAHAB I ZERO THAT CONSENT
CALENDARS OUT. DID YOU SAY 9 TO
0 9 TO 0. OKAY. NOW WE'LL MOVE
TO ITEM THREE AB 211 FOR IRWIN
AND THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
JUDICIARY. CURRENT VOTE OF 6 TO
0. SENATOR CABALLERO GUERRERO I
PADILLA UMBERG I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WAHAB I 9 TO 0 OKAY SO AB 2114
IS OUT WITH A VOTE OF 9 TO 0.
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING? OKAY. AND WE'LL NOW GO
TO AB 2338 JOAN SAWYER AND THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO HUMAN
SERVICES. LET'S DO ROLL. CALL
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0 WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING. SENATOR
CABALLERO, MENGIBAR PADILLA.
CIERTO UMBERG UMBERG I WAHAB
WAHAB I. THAT'S 5 TO 0. BALANCE
YEAH. IT DIDN'T PASS. HOW DO WE.
BECAUSE PADILLA WAS MOVED HERE
BECAUSE. IT DOES FEEL A
CONSIDERATION, WE, WE WILL GRANT
THAT BILL RECONSIDERATION THÀNH.
SO LET'S NOW MOVE TO, ITEM NINE
AB 2897. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6
TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
PADILLA UMBERG A UMBERG I WAHAB
WAHAB I 9 TO 0IN FAVOR.
ALL RIGHT, DID WE FINISH THAT
ROLL CALL? YES 9 TO 0. OKAY,
THAT BILL IS OUT, 9 TO 0. WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE, ITEM TEN AB
2967 TÍNH. THAT'S Dð. PASS TO
THE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO
0 WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. SENATOR CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. PADILLA SERRATO.
UMBERG UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. THAT'S 8 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILLS OUT 8 TO 0.
WE'LL NOW GO TO AB 3035.
PELLERIN AND ITS Dð PASS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH A CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
PADILLA. UMBERG. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 9 TO 0.
GREAT. WE'LL GO TO THE LAST
ITEM. ITEM 13 AJR9 MACKINNON.
IT'S, REFERRED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. SENATOR. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. PADILLA UMBERG.
UMBERG I WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILLS OUT 7 TO 2.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE CONCLUDED
WE WILL SEE YOU ALL NEXT WEEK.
TWO WEEKS IN TWO WEEKS FROM NOW.
OKAY. THANKS VERY MUCH, THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.